you want to know what what
transgenderism is all about I've got a
clip for you right here this this is a
clip it's just going around of the new
owner of the Miss Universe contest this
is what transgenderism is all about
welcome to the Miss Universe
organization
from now on it's gonna be
ran by women
[Applause]
for our women really around the world to
celebrate the power of feminism
diverse cultures
social inclusion
gender equality
creativity the Force for good and of
course the beauty of humanity
so
do you think you need a study to know
that something is wrong about that that
person is jacaphong chakra jujitip
probably mispronouncing that name he
goes by Anne he used to go by Andrew he
is the current owner of Miss Universe
Miss USA and Miss Teen USA
beauty pageant organizations and he is a
fella who has had some surgery to make
him look more like a woman
and and he says that the contest is now
run by women
I don't think he's really fooling
anybody and the clip is going viral
specifically because he's not fooling
anybody he's not fooling the
conservatives he's not fooling the
feminists it's very offensive to to
women I think to say hey ladies yeah us
us gals you know we're here we're
finally running Miss Teen USA and Miss
Universe and all the rest of it isn't
that girl power huh the women are
thinking uh
this is not
I think I'm kind of being had here I
don't this I don't think that the women
are actually running these pageants yet
right right of course not but everybody
looks at that we say okay we know that
something's wrong with that
I I urge people always to to
cultivate a conservative Insight it's
one that Russell Kirk talks about a lot
it's one that Edmund Burke one of the
founders of modern conservatism talked
about a lot
and that is
trust your prejudices
most of the time
not all of the time you can have unjust
prejudices and that that can be a bad
thing
but most of the time your prejudices are
going to be correct because your
prejudices are pre-judgments and
prejudgments are the way that we have to
operate in the world because for every
decision that we make we make countless
decisions all the time where we're going
to walk what we're going to wear who
we're going to talk to what we're going
to say what we're going to drink what
we're going to sit down and do
what's going to distract our attention
will we answer the phone we make these
decisions all the time and we don't
write 50 Page Long treatises of
perfectly rational explanations as to
why we make those decisions or why we
feel a certain way about certain things
we couldn't do that we wouldn't be able
to operate in the world if we did that
and so we've got to rely on our gut
we've got to rely on our Instinct we've
got to rely on just prejudices which is
to say the inherited wisdom that we have
from our tradition
you might not be able to articulate
precisely why it is wrong that a dude
who's had a bunch of weird surgeries and
is wearing stilettos is prancing around
on stage calling himself a woman and
taking over Miss Universe in the name of
women you might not be able to
articulate on the perfect rational way
why it's wrong for a man to go into a
girl's bathroom I think given enough
time you probably could but you might
not be able to right on the spot that's
okay you still know it's wrong and you
know it's wrong because of something
that Leon casts the great bioethicist
referred to as the wisdom of repugnance
you know that that's wrong it's okay to
know that you don't need some scientist
to give you permission to know the
things that you already know the
scientists are wrong most of the time
anyway
speaking of the weird trans stuff there
is a young teenager really sad story
California teenager who was exposed to
some naked man at the YMCA while she was
she was getting changed this is Rebecca
Phillips just 17 years old she explained
this disgusting situation during public
comments at the January 11 Santee city
council meeting
my name is Rebecca Phillips and I'm 17
years old
I am not a resident of Santee but I am
employed at a local restaurant The
Omelette Factory and I work out
regularly at the Santee YMCA
just two weeks ago after finishing my
shift at my job I went to the gym to
swim laps
as I was showering after my workout I
saw a naked male in the women's locker
room
I immediately went back into the shower
terrified and hid behind their flimsy
excuse for a curtain until he was gone
I ran into a bathroom stall to change as
quickly as I could organizing my
thoughts to share with the people at the
front desk when I asked the YMCA
management what their policy was
regarding transgenders they confirmed
that the man that I saw was indeed
allowed to shower wherever he pleased
as long as you are not a red flag on
Megan's Law
the California sex offender registry a
grown male can shower alongside a
teenage girl at your YMCA location here
in Santee
I was made to feel as though I had done
something wrong when I talked to people
at the YMCA
an absurd story obviously this teenage
girl should not be made to shower with
naked dudes because those dudes happen
to have some sexual perversion that
makes them derive pleasure out of
pretending to be a woman and stripping
down in front of little girls obviously
that is the case and she says you know I
was made to feel wrong about my natural
feelings of disgust and fear at seeing
some dude strip down naked in the girls
room I was made to feel wrong like
that's bigoted like that's prejudiced
obviously that's not wrong obviously
she's right
she this girl with her natural
prejudices is right and most of the
scientific establishment today that
pushes this woke PC line of
transgenderism in all their lab coats
with all their microscopes they're
completely wrong like they are wrong a
lot of the time like they were wrong
about what they told us about covid and
the vaccines and and lobotomies and
leaching and so many of the other wacky
scientific theories that have come up
over time
so girl 100 right not her fault at all
now I have a I think a deeper reaction
to this that I haven't heard anyone else
bring up and it's probably going to be
controversial and Media Matters is
probably clipping this out right now but
I don't care because I think actually
the fact that nobody is talking about
this is why conservatives so frequently
lose in the culture
why do women go to the YMCA
it's the YMCA
what's that the young men's Christian
Association
why do women go there now there used to
be
something like the y w c a young women's
associations there are gyms for women
there are all sorts of things for women
why is it now that everything has to be
totally mixed
I'm not I'm not saying it's this girl's
why did this girl go to the YMCA I know
she was invited to the YMCA she's
probably a member at the YMCA I'm asking
why does the YMCA admit women and why do
why why does our culture want women to
go to the YMCA why can't there be
separate spaces in in certain fields for
men and for women
well because
increasingly we're told that men and
women are not different they're not
complementary they're interchangeable
and it's not just the libs who believe
that the libs are the ones who pushed it
but many conservatives have accepted
that as the truth
and what conservatives do is we always
just fight the craziest newest symptom
of a cultural error that goes much much
deeper
so what you'll hear conservatives say is
well listen
I don't care about
what weird sex stuff you all do and I
don't care about I don't care about gay
marriage I don't care about feminism I
don't care about this that and the other
thing you everybody can do whatever they
want
and I don't care if a man wants to put
on a dress and get his body chopped up
by a doctor if he's over 18. I don't
care about any of that but don't do it
with the kids
yeah I don't care about listen I don't
care if you go in and read a bunch of
stories in a crazy sexualized outfit
it's part of drag queen Story Hour to
fifth graders but don't do it to third
graders that was actually the argument
in Florida well in Florida which good on
Florida they went out and they banned
this kind of weird grooming
trans-education stuff
in elementary schools they only did it
from pre-k through the third grade
in fact one of the
jokey ways to refer to the bill was the
wait till eight Bill and then it
starting at nine years old
then you can be exposed to all this kind
of transgender propaganda just don't do
it to the eight-year-olds
okay well maybe to the eight-year-olds
but don't do it to the five-year-olds
okay five well don't trans the
two-year-olds and we just keep
retreating
but transgenderism is the natural
consequence of this fundamental error
that men and women are interchangeable
and that's an error that goes back not
just to gay marriage
that's an error that goes back not just
to the gay rights movement of the 1990s
that's an error that goes back at the
very least to feminism
because all of these movements take part
of the same faulty premise feminism says
a woman needs a man like a fish needs a
bicycle men and women are exactly the
same the only difference is that our
bodies look a little bit different and
even then that's not a big deal
okay if that's true then then obviously
you're going to have the normalization
of
homosexual relations if if a man and a
woman is the same thing as a man and a
man the same thing as a woman as a woman
then it's all the same and if you're
going to do that then you have to
redefine marriage and if you're going to
do that if a man and a woman are exactly
the same then why the hell can't that
guy shower in in the the locker room
with a 17 year old girl
why not men and women are exactly the
same oh okay you're willing to admit
finally that men and women are not
exactly the same well then how far back
are you going to take that
are you going to take that back to
men and women have different roles
within a marriage
that marriage therefore has a special
meaning and that sexual differences at
the heart of that that men and women
have different roles within a political
community and within Society willing to
say that even many conservatives
probably would not want to do that
because it's not just the libs
one problem is conservatives are very
often just fighting for the liberal
position five years ago
and that's why we keep losing head on
over become a member right now use code
Knowles Canada wles dailywire.com
Knowles use code nulls at checkout for
two months free on all annual plans
[Music]
[Music]